back in 2008
someone suggested i watched the secret
and i was like
okay
and
what year did it come out
206. okay 2006. so
so it had been around for a bit but i
had watched it and it was spring of 2008
and then i don't know if it was the
exact next race it might have been
because i i was a race car driver yes
yes um
and the next race was my race in japan
that i finally won in indycar
and i always connect the dots between
watching the secret right and winning in
japan right right and so thank you so
much oh gosh you did it
thank you you're the one who did it so
yeah it's been 2006 until now
unrecognizable life for me i have to say
compared to prior to 2006
when i was just
totally asleep to everything
so
it's really good to be conscious it is
but it's a journey at the same time oh
it's a journey
yeah it is but it's wonderful journey
yeah it's like you talk to anybody
that's on the journey of waking up of
consciousness of healing of any of those
things and
you know it can there can be really
rough periods where you have to face a
lot of things and look at yourself and
the things that you've denied or the
things that you've not nurtured or
cultivated whether it be inner child or
whether it be
relationships or the way you show up and
how you feel about them and how you
project
but at the end of the day it's always a
rise in frequency and it's always a
greater
a greater existence on a daily basis
like your baseline changes it does
and you you just become i wouldn't have
been able to recognize this i don't
think going back to 2006 but
you
you become
freer
so my first step to freedom was
definitely the realization of the secret
and that we
can create our lives whichever way we
want to create them that was just the
most massive
breath of freedom um and and was
incredible and so my life completely
changed from that uh 360 360 in every
single area but then
i always felt well if if this is the
case
then there must be more that i don't
know and so i just became a crazy crazy
sincere seeker i just read every book
that was going i went back through time
i was going through all of the
traditions and the religions i just
could not get enough
and
and i was doing it 24 7 and i could do
it 24 7 because it was really my work so
so it was amazing to be able to do it
just so blessed well that's an example
of doing something endlessly
and getting you're like so energized for
it and insatiable for it because it's so
your purpose
i was not the least bit tired i had to
force myself to go to sleep i couldn't
wait to wake up in the morning and so i
could keep going and doing more and more
and more and i had so many realizations
over those years
one after the other after the other
after the other aha moments that
completely changed the way that i saw
the world and the way that i saw myself
and it just kept continuing that way and
so the more realizations that i had the
more that i could see the way things
really are the happier i became the
happier i became happier happier happy
happier and
less able to be disturbed
by
people and events
well what was the first story what is
the first story that you wrote it was
like
being
hit with a truck or or enlightened
probably not in in a negative way but
what was that first thing that that aha
that epiphany that happened that made
you realize that got you into
the path that led to the secret
it was a particular evening
and i had had a really really rough year
that year my father had died suddenly
and i was making six movies about
unsolved murders so it's a really really
rough subject i had a production company
and so everything that could go wrong
went wrong that year until i reached
september the 9th
and i had two phone calls in a row
and it was time so beautifully when i
look back was incredible because the
first phone call absolutely brought me
to my knees and that was my accountant
saying you're going to you're going to
be broke in 30 days you've gone two
million dollars over budget on the
movies and i still had one and a half to
deliver
um and i had a had a director and we've
gone over budget and then i hung up the
phone and as i had the phone it rang
again it was my mother and he was in a
really bad way so those two phone calls
absolutely brought me to my knees
because i
didn't feel that i could
solve either problem like i was so good
at fixing things but these two things my
mother was grief-stricken
because my father had died earlier in
the year and so these two things i could
not solve and and so i just collapsed in
despair and that moment of collapsing in
despair
was the moment where my life would
change forever
because my daughter
my adult daughter saw me
and just walked out and handed me this
book which was from 1910 and said read
this little help
and i mean
i've asked her since why did you give me
that book
and she's like i don't know you know she
just didn't know she was just and the
way that she gave it to me was almost
kind of
um robot like do you know like just uh
handing it
what's even weirder
is that with with the sky falling in
after the two phone calls is that
i read the book
right you made time for the book i just
sat down right there and then and i and
i opened it up and i started reading and
all my tears were hitting the pages the
ink was running and 90 minutes later i'd
finished reading it and oh my gosh
my life had completely changed i knew
things
that were
not in that book
i just re had the biggest biggest
realization of course the book was the
trigger and the book is called the
science of getting rich by wallace
wattles and it's available for free on
our website
if anybody wants to download it the
sacred tv but that book
i just saw so much in that book and that
set me off on a search from that book
onward i went back into time
searching for this information that i
absolutely knew was the truth that we
created our life and i just went back
right back through history actually way
back to the emerald tablet and i didn't
tell anybody what i'd found i just
continued to research and it's like what
you were talking about
i just
there was something rushing through me
that
just took me i i i barely slept
and then it was almost like like i would
pick up a book and i would start to read
it and i would read that book and i then
i would look at the time and think oh
it's really late and it was five minutes
from when i last looked at it like it
was like time stopped and it was like
time became really malleable for me
and so
yeah well that's a reality time in space
this is this dimension you like you like
were in a different
reality a different dimension where time
wasn't relevant